hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Breanna white Breanna white and I are
gonna watch the trailer for fantastic
beasts and where to find them where do
you find the fantastic beasts somewhere
in the Harry Potter world apparently I
don't know anything about this is it a
prequel or sequel neither actual just a
spinoff it's just a spin-off yeah but
does it you know we don't know if it
takes place after the events of it
before it takes in it takes place in
1926 in New York so takes place in
earlier years it's not exactly prequel
just the spin off story in this thing
the idea is that in the first Harry
Potter book he gets a textbook that's
required reading for all of Hogwarts and
this movie is based off that textbook I
suppose that could be fun let's watch
this she loves Harry Potter damn we got
away oh gosh
Happy House need
yesterday wizard added new york with the
case
oh she wrote it yeah
became full of magical creatures
then unfortunately some have escaped
I was hoping just a swish it's just me
that looks pretty sweet please don't be
over
I have full-body chills right now really
are you like me you get the NIT chills
I'm so excited
full-body chills that's all she that's
how she's gonna answer it I'm so excited
that's how she's gonna answer
Oh David Yates returned for the yes
that's why it couldn't be so [ __ ]
good okay Wow holy [ __ ]
they're like pulling no punches a few
things that get me excited for this not
so much the trailer but the information
behind the trailer like hearing that JK
Rowling is is rolling a rally it's
rolling to her okay Americans in
traveling know you've been pronouncing
your name wrong all these years and
David Yates who did like the last few
Harry Potter films which arguably were
the best one absolutely they were
genre-defining movie absolutely every
major trilogy after that formed itself
based on the Harry Potter movies and he
knew how to also take these sequels but
also make them a little bit different
each time in terms of tone and stuff
totally you know he could provide
something different for this I know he's
just doing The Legend of Tarzan right
now the fact that you got the same
filmmakers onboard and in the original
author of the very pottery war gives me
a lot of faith and how this is gonna
turn out
at least totally yeah you know because
that's so much that's so important when
it comes to Harry Potter is like the
magic of the world you know this movie
is probably going to receive a lot of
criticism just for the fact that it's a
spin-off of the Harry Potter world and
there's gonna be people out there who
are gonna be like can't you just let the
franchise go and stuff yes there will
there will always be that but you also
have to consider that most people are
never going to be done because it's such
an inclusive world and you know this
game could be the same for Star Wars for
Star Wars exactly but everyone's still
hyped about that I don't think that
that's something to be concerned about
but the other thing you also have is all
the previous movies were based off the
books and so people already knew about
all these characters and every single
detail about the plot and things like
that
this is something that's completely
different it's just for film there was a
book but it was it was a textbook like I
said it
Harry Potter's textbook in one of the in
one of the books the plot of the movie
isn't necessarily as explicitly defined
and JK Rowling is the screenwriter yeah
the only screenwriter and this is the
first screenplay I think she's written I
think that'd be interesting to see how
it I'm very interested to transfers into
the Harry Potter specific story that we
know of I think that would be a new
thing to do down the road not in the
first movie yeah I think in the first
movie
just let it be its own thing I really
don't want a lot of learn minders of
Harry Potter like I hate it when
spin-off or a prequel does that is when
it's like let's remind you all the time
of what this is originally from so I
want it to just be its own thing Freddy
uh what's his name Eddie Redmayne Eddie
Freddy Eddie Redmayne fantastic actor
he's one of the best actors around right
now yeah it's cool because he's the lead
of it when Daniel Radcliffe was
introduced to us through Harry Potter
this wonder getting an actor who's
already well-known to be the lead in it
already has an Oscar probably gonna get
another one for the Danish girl I feel
like the Harry Potter world it's perfect
for spin-offs
there's yes so much story that could be
told more than Harry Potter of course
that's something to consider you know
when you have something like Lord of the
Rings which is also equally as immersive
and then you get something like The
Hobbit which they did after the original
Lord of the Rings movie and the Hobbit
was such a huge letdown I was really
hoping that fantastic beasts and where
to find them doesn't go that direction I
doubt it will Jay King around dinner
Rowling Cheam read any the Harry Potter
movies right correct Wow
none of them that gets me that makes me
want to see it just because to see her
first screenplay that's what I'm scared
of though I'm worried because you know
novelists are allowed to put everything
into their novels and it just adds a
page but with movies you can't really do
that you feel like it might be a little
cramped yeah I read that it'll get a
little bit too you know too many beasts
or too many characters too convoluted
and in a movie format you know I don't
want to sit through a three-hour movie
as much as I loved Harry Potter I don't
want to fit through a three-hour movie
well I don't feel like they're trying to
top the epic scale just yet I feel like
I just it's just a teaser trailer but
they didn't show us like a bunch of
ran shots and everything so maybe it's
more toned down to the point where she
doesn't have to deal with as many
characters who knows you know what she
is a little bit susceptible to is
fanservice and I'm also worried about
this particular movie being a little bit
more about that and about telling an
epic story
first of all it's set in America which
is none of the other Harry Potter
stories are so this is the first one
that's really made for a specifically
American audience which I'm a little bit
worried and excited about it the same
yeah yeah you know interesting I didn't
realize it was a Senate America
yeah it's that innate well so it's gonna
be automatically better cuz America is
the greatest country on this [ __ ]
planet I'm actually a little bit worried
about the opposite is it gonna take away
some of the magic because it's not sent
in a foreign country no making it
American makes everything better this is
a good movie already I support this film
America yeah it looks cool you got solid
filmmakers behind it you got a solid
lead actor in it it's probably gonna be
a good movie you know like I I doubt
it's gonna suck I doubt it's gonna suck
although you know like they brought back
Peter Jackson to do The Hobbit films
when it was originally Guillermo del
Toro and I thought Guerra Mel del Toro
would have brought a totally different
take and it would have been more unique
and interesting to watch that's where my
one concern comes in of David Yates
director David Yates is gonna be just a
little bit done with the series and he's
not going to put his heart into it as
much or he might like I don't know it
might seem too reminiscent of Harry
Potter because he defined the Harry
Potter Styles for the last few movies
yeah so I feel like we might get too
much of that but the movie is so
everything about it is so different I'm
kind of okay with everything else being
the same style room the way the movies
made should stay the same because
everything else is so different we still
want to feel that emotional connection
to that world
Wow good point you know you may have
persuaded me but that's the thing you
know it could go either way I'm just I
want it to be so good you really are
excited I love Harry Potter wow did you
ever think for Daniel Radcliffe no
there would be a little bit when I was
young see that photo with his penis
oh when he did that play when he did
Equus yeah
you see the penis I didn't see the
picture it's a nice penis okay like a
nice looking Venus I'm sure he's solid
shiny penis he wouldn't have done it
yeah well I would have but I would have
regretted it I still would have done it
cuz people would have found it funny but
on the inside I'd be dying this is sad
that's where you find the fantastic
pieces down there you know what I mean I
mean Breanna you know I mean dad doesn't
watch us anymore right you know what I
mean anyway guys listen if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe today
become a reject Breanna White has a
gaming channel check it out it's called
sibling rivalry follow her there
immediately